Welcome John to the scheme of Russell
brand.
My guest today is Andy [inaudible],
the accomplished presenter and writer
and he's the cofounder and voice of the
headspace app in his early twenties
midway through a university degree in
sports science and he made the
unexpected decision to travel to the
Himalayas to study meditation.
Instead,
it was the beginning of a 10 year
journey,
which took him around the world.
Como La,
culminating with ordination as a Tibet
and Buddhist monk in northern India.
He's transitioned back to normal life in
2004 sorry,
I'm training briefly at Moscow state
circus before returning to London to
complete a degree in circus arts with
the conservatoire of dance and drama
whilst drawing up the early plans for
what was later to become headspace.
Welcome andy to under the skin.
Thanks Russell.
Even though under the skin in this
instance is taking place in your studio
where you actually welcomed the
headspace.
Thank you very much.
It's very generous of you to,
we've never done this before and under
the skin we've always recorded it,
you know,
in various places.
In London,
we're in Los Angeles now.
We're in a one of the facilities of
headspace and it's wonderful to be here.
The reason that I was strongly motivated
to meet you was because people kept
mentioning headspace in under the skin
at Stafford,
the a survival expert and I call him the
grunge bear grylls.
Not that I don't love bear grylls would
be straight standard bear grylls
vanilla.
I love that guy too,
but it's Stafford.
He's like the Nirvana version.
He loves headspace and more and more
people were mentioning headspace to me
and I thought I'm going to have to meet
the people that are headspace.
Thanks for coming in and this by the
way,
I held this place you,
you're very welcome.
If you're,
if you're in La,
this is lovely to hear your voice.
Thank you very much.
I will take you,
I'll take you up on that.
Thank you.
That's really very generous of you.
Now what as defined to headspace thus
far,
even though I know it's been a 10 year
journey is it seems to me and and I,
I used the APP myself that you are
making a meditation accessible,
fun.
Hello,
quill.
Hopefully I think you are.
I love the little animation videos at
that and they're like,
what the reference points are for those
creatures that I don't know quite what
they are,
but I like him.
I love your tone.
I was talking to someone,
I'm over here acting at the moment and
uh,
I was talking to another actor on set
and he was talking about meditation,
the challenges that he faces.
It goes,
you want to do headspace mate?
Like it's just like a British bloke
going,
all right,
sit down.
Remember,
you don't need to shut your eyes.
Just relax.
It's not complicated.
And maybe,
hopefully you've watched the video.
If you haven't,
you might want to watch that now.
Like I don't,
and I sort of like what I feel like part
of what I've been trying to do myself is
to make,
not meditation because I'm not qualified
to bring it to people,
but certainly the conversation around
spirituality,
I wanted to make it more accessible.
Tell me how this journey began for you.
Uh,
the journey into
meditation or headspace.
More specifically,
I think initially headspace.
How come you,
when I'm going to set up an APP and
popularized meditation,
how have you done this?
Yeah,
well,
it's important to say,
so I'm,
I'm just,
I'm just a,
I'm a cofounder,
so the other cofounder,
rich,
um,
rich pearson,
so very,
very dear friend now.
And this was,
uh,
was something that we came up with
together and we've had an amazing team
of people and also I love so much love
and support from people along the way.
I think an ungrateful person because
you're the real deal.
I knew you're a monk so you're not this
brilliant idea of Ed space and I'm going
to smash it.
You're obviously is totally humble
person to tune into the limitless,
but it's also the truth as well.
Cool.
We meet rich,
so we,
um,
I,
I left.
Um,
so I left the monastery and,
and decided to start teaching.
I was doing,
um,
one-to-one in a clinic back in,
back in London.
So this was,
you know,
we'll look at the circus thing later.
Um,
but kind of after the,
the circus,
I was kind of okay.
I knew kind of the language that I
wanted to use and w and I knew by then
what techniques,
so I kind of felt would work outside of
the need to even feel compelled to do
that.
And why did you think I want to
popularize meditation?
What was the sense that you had that it
was necessary?
This isn't,
this is more tricky cause it wasn't,
it wasn't like a,
a plan.
So in the same way people asking you,
why did you go away and become a monk?
I felt an overwhelming sense that that
was what I had to do.
And I wasn't able to necessarily put it
into two words.
And I didn't come up with a list of pros
and cons of,
of being a monk and not being a monk in
the same way when I left the monastery,
I guess if it's helpful to take a step
back and when I was teaching meditation,
so I had,
um,
uh,
the monastery had asked me to teach at a
meditation center in Moscow and I ended
up living there for just over four
years,
four and a half years.
And I would see different types of
people and I'd often get expats coming
along and they really wanted to learn
meditation and they really wanted the
benefits of meditation,
but they didn't necessarily want to
adopt a faith.
They didn't necessarily want to chat to
a guy in robes and to come into this
kind of place where there was a lot of
ritual and tradition.
So that was,
I think,
the beginning of me thinking,
well,
there's this need and what's more
important to me?
Is it teaching meditation or is it being
a monk?
And I felt very strongly that teaching
meditation was,
was more useful and that I could present
it in a way that I,
you know,
I didn't,
it didn't matter whether I was wearing a
shirt and tie or whether I was,
whether I was wearing kind of ropes,
you know?
So that was the beginning.
I would say.
What's the best thing about being a
monk?
Strange as it may sound,
not having anything because there's
nothing to worry about.
So yeah,
freedom you give,
you give away.
I mean,
which is strange because you're living
within four walls and it's very kind of
institutionalized in some ways.
But within that there is a,
you know,
freedoms from within and there was a,
an inner feeling of freedom and there's
no,
you don't have to achieve anything.
You'd have to prove anything.
You don't have to worry about losing
anything.
You own nothing that there's,
so there's a real sense of freedom in
that.
In your case,
it was a Tibetan monastery in the
Himalayas,
is that correct?
So it was,
uh,
I started in Himalayas and then I went
to Burma and trained in a,
in a Burmese monastery.
And then eventually I ended up kind of,
uh,
going back to Tibetan monastery and
doing five years.
And it's about in tradition.
Yeah.
Really?
And you,
the relationship with the guru,
I teach her,
it's kind of sacred thing,
isn't it?
Who is your teacher?
He is.
So,
um,
I think there,
there are different types of teachers
along the way,
you know,
so there were more kind of instructor
kind of type teachers are there,
people who they're the real deal,
they've,
they've put in the time and they've done
it.
But there,
there may be not kind of considered sort
of like as a,
as a guru or something like that.
And someone who was incredibly important
in my own personal kind of journey was
a,
he's an Irishman called,
called Donald and Donald Donald was a
real deal.
Like he,
he was,
he trained and he did just over 12 years
in,
in retreat,
in longterm retreat.
Um,
where did you encounter him and were
already done them 12 years.
So he did 12 years.
He was,
he was on his way to the Himalayas and
he stopped off at a monastery
[inaudible] monastery in Scotland,
which is back in the 60s.
It just opened,
it just started.
And the Abbot of the monastery persuaded
him to stay and do a six month retreat
rather than go to India.
And he finished a six month or to treat.
And they said,
well,
look,
we're just about to start the first
three and a half year retreat,
you know,
would you,
it's the first one in the west.
It's kind of ever happened.
The Tibetans have this three and a half
year retreat,
you know,
would you like to do it?
And Oh yeah,
okay.
It's fairly easy kind of going guy.
And he was like,
yeah,
sure,
I'll try it.
And so he did that one and then he did
another one and then he did another one.
And by the time I met him,
he'd,
he'd left the monastery.
He was never a monk,
so he was in that,
you know,
he went through that process,
but he did it as a lay person.
And,
um,
by the time I met him,
he was in Moscow and that was my main
kind of reason for going out to Moscow
to meet him and train with him.
And you wanted to meet him?
I really want it.
Why did you want to,
I just met the,
the Abbot of the monastery in Scotland.
I'd gone back there and,
um,
a friend invite me along and I remember
just seeing the picture of this guy,
you know,
and it said that he was at the Moscow
kind of center and there was just,
there was something about him which
resonated.
And I felt really strongly that there
was,
there was something for me to,
to better understand and learn.
And because he'd gone through that
journey,
he'd come to as a westerner,
he'd gone through,
he'd kind of,
my understanding of it is,
is that he'd sort of transcended the,
the,
the tradition.
So he was no longer kind of stuck with
the words and the concept and the
frameworks.
And so he kind of operated outside of
that,
which allowed him to communicate in a
way which just struck a chord,
which I'd never really kind of
experienced before because I'd always
been in foreign monasteries where it
was,
you know,
this is how it is and it's like this.
And always the same language was used.
And so he kind of cut through that for
me and helped me see in a,
in a really different way.
I think that somehow you in,
that's obviously significant as you go
on along with your partner and your team
to become the founder of headspace that
are significant men or for you with
someone that didn't use the conventional
traditional lexicon by in fact
colloquially taught,
taught meditation,
which is precisely what headspace does
now for 20 million users.
So I can see why he would be a
significant figure,
but it also seems significant to me,
Andy,
that the,
uh,
impulse to connect with this guy seem
very intuitive,
very instinctive.
What's that about do you think?
Yeah,
yeah.
I think maybe I'm just kind of rash.
I tend,
I tend to kind of move from instinct I
would say or you know,
I,
I tend not to over overthink things.
So whether it was kind of going away and
becoming a monk and that felt like just
so intuitively the right thing to do.
Um,
I did it in the same did you did,
what was that?
I mean from Bristol in England,
aren't ya?
You're just a bloke from Bristol in
England,
that's suddenly you're a monk in the
Himalayas,
then you're,
there's a bit where you're nearly in the
center.
Cause my mate Gareth,
which uses the shower,
his biography sounds like a lie that
you'd make up to impress a girl for a
while.
Then I was in the circus then I was a
necessity in for a couple of weeks.
They removed that part.
Kevin Keegan Mad Celtic life.
He sounds,
it does sound bizarre.
I think if you,
if you look at it as a,
um,
there's no way of explaining away the
monk to circus monk the clown bit.
But um,
basically until the age of 21,
I competed in gymnastics.
So kind of,
I had the acrobatic kind of background.
I then went to become a monk and for 10
years I didn't know exercise and that
was something that I really,
really missed.
So as soon as I had the opportunity,
you can't,
you can't exercise as a monk.
So as soon as I finished being a monk,
why,
why can't,
why he's meditating all day?
That's it.
Just sitting around,
sitting around with your eyes closed,
not doing anything.
Exactly.
So and I was desperate to kind of go
back and do,
do that.
So that was the first thing I did when I
stopped being a monk.
And so yeah.
And so you know,
I went back to do an acrobatics and
stuff and I transitioned a bit of
extremists mate,
one minute,
next minute year moncton and going to be
in a circus now it sounds like that
focus and concentration,
one of the things he seems like he must
have and also as a,
as I say when I listened to you on
headspace interest in tea,
you say other stuff like it's a like you
must have a good relationship with your
inner life concentration and focus for
an acrobat concentration and focus for
gymnasts,
concentration,
focus and aspect might say of uh,
of meditation.
So you're you but you pursued the
monastic path.
Yeah,
we briefly spoke upstairs and like
monastic life is determined by a
structure,
isn't it?
You get up at a certain time,
you eat certain things and evidently
you're not allowed to do any bloody
size.
So like how long did you live that life?
So I lived there on and off.
So I started as a,
as a lay person,
um,
uh,
in,
in northern India.
And then so I went,
became a novice monk,
so I moved to,
uh,
moved to Burma.
Um,
and then I went and went on to become a
monk in Tibet.
Introducers over a period of,
of 10 of 10 years.
And these transitions,
are they marked by Sarah many and
commitment?
What are these transitions?
How would I mark [inaudible] some are,
yeah.
I think when you become a novice monk
there's a ceremony and I think it
becomes a bit more formal as you become
a fully ordained monk.
So it was,
I didn't bring the pictures are
upstairs,
but I'm definitely going to look,
you've got shaved that now.
I mean it's different.
I mean did you look,
cause when I first met you it just then
like,
oh yeah,
he's a monk back are sort of like,
you know,
people that got a vibe.
Like I've tried to lighten it up.
Cause you knew though,
cause he knew I used to be probably,
yeah.
Probably there was confirmation bias,
but also also there was the sense I I me
my background in addiction,
you sense when people have like we have
drug addicts,
they're not present like well whatever
type of drug it is,
there think mostly their life when
they're not taking drugs is just the
thing that they have to deal with in
order to get back to drugs.
Now we have spiritual meditation.
People I impact it has on me is it makes
me vibrate a bit or I don't know,
I like,
it keeps me up.
I something about it.
I like,
and I remember when I was a little kid
that we're not looking at us 25 seven so
when I was 27 I met this gaze there.
That was a sort of hardcore swami rather
not swamis from the Harry Krishna sect.
Right.
And when I met him it was like I got a
real buzz off it.
It was like a meat and a beautiful woman
actually.
It was like,
I was like,
Oh God,
I really want to impress him.
I like him a lot of goal.
It so exciting.
And I recognize,
and then when you read autobiography of
a Yogi,
I'm like,
when Yogananda talks about his guru,
his great love,
great passion.
So yeah,
I mean if I think,
you know,
you talking just now about kind of gurus
and stuff and I'll start off with
teaching.
If I think about sort of the first time
I met who I would consider to be sort of
like guru type sort of status.
Is that that Irish it Donald?
No,
it's not.
It's um,
it's a chap called his holiness the come
up and who escaped from Tibet,
um,
when he was 17 years old because of what
Chinese occupation and I met him back in
a,
those are quite serious threat to his
life.
So I met him,
um,
back,
I don't know,
late 1990,
something like that.
And I remember the f even I knew nothing
about him.
And the first time I met him,
I can own only described that moment as
completely limitless in nature.
And whether you define limitless bye,
bye love,
bye space.
By time there was a feeling of
connection,
which I had never experienced up until
that kind of point.
And it was without any of the kind of,
as I say that the baggage of association
or anything else.
I didn't really kind of know much about
him.
He was 17 year old,
17 years old.
So he was like a kid.
He was a kid,
he could,
he was 17,
but he could have been 80 or 90 years
old.
There was something about him which was
completely timeless,
ageless.
And that for me was the beginning of a
very different kind of journey into
meditation.
I would say.
What happened to you in retrospect?
I think,
um,
I mean it shattered a lot of kind of
illusions I might have had,
but it also was the beginning of,
um,
sort of,
I guess a journey of devotion as well.
And I think devotion is often kind of
talked about in,
in different different ways.
I'm not talking about a blind devotion,
but a real sense of something being,
and it was personified by that person,
but it wasn't really about that person.
It was something kind of bigger and yet
there was a a direction for that.
Again,
whether you think of his devotion or
love or whatever there was,
it felt like it had a very definite sort
of direction and purpose.
So I felt just the connection that I'd
never,
I'd never experienced before.
Inescapably Andy,
we are talking about quite profound
ideas,
profound and powerful energies that some
wallet supersede the colloquial and
secularized world of the headspace APP,
which I think he's a brilliant,
brilliant tool,
but part of the compromise it's
continually made,
excuse me,
when reaching out to what we would say,
you know,
we would call secular people are
nonreligious people or people that
aren't spiritual,
you continually.
So again,
it's just a thing just to help you
relax,
just making more effective at work.
Right?
And then how do we fit this together
with this stuff that I'm kind of into,
which like seven year old kid that's
like the golden child.
It's conveying some limitless,
infinite wisdom makes these person are
irrelevant.
Like you sense God in someone or you
know,
and again that's a complicated word,
but the limitless to use your term,
how do we align that with the needs of
headspace?
Is it because you look at them as
separate things or what?
I really don't actually.
I think it's um,
it's been a journey that has just kind
of evolved and um,
I feel like w to suggest it's gone full
circle suggests that something has been
achieved.
And I don't mean it in that way.
I mean simply I've been on a journey
where I started off with one particular
kind of language in a way of kind of
looking at the world and thinking about
things I found.
I went through another kind of period
where I was using different language and
looking at the world in a different kind
of way.
And then I came back to a situation
where I'm using the old language but to,
to kind of refer back to that.
And for me they're not different.
And I personally,
I think the danger of kind of having any
kind of labels like normal people or
spiritual people,
I think that is defined that the essence
is defined by being present.
And I think as soon as we take on the
label of being spiritual or
nonspiritual,
then we stepped away from the essence
that we're trying to kind of describe.
So I don't feel like there's a
difference.
There's definitely,
I,
you know,
we're talking about staff using
different,
I wouldn't talk about this kind of in,
in the APP because I don't feel like
it's the most helpful,
most relevant thing for the person
coming to the APP.
But as we kind of,
as we kind of dig a bit deeper,
I think,
you know,
is relevant to my personal kind of
journey.
Um,
and all of that informs kind of what has
gone into the APP.
None.
Nothing in the APP is not my own idea.
Nothing is kind of been invented by me.
It's really me just kind of taking,
you know,
other people's wisdom and trying to kind
of bring it together in a way that feels
right for people like us,
right,
who don't live in a monastery,
of course.
Yes,
there is no,
it doesn't in any way undermine or
compromise the content of the APP to say
that someone that's been a monk for 10
years is going to have had different
experiences than someone who's just
picking up their phone and going off and
online 10 minutes where I'm not worrying
about my job or wherever it is.
You know,
that's obviously distinct is obviously
something that you've dedicated a great
deal of exploration toward.
And there's many things I'm fascinated
about here,
mate,
because like when we talk about the,
uh,
the,
the devotion that is in here within a
guru student system,
when you talk about the discipline and
structures that were,
um,
prevalent in your monastic life,
it is in escapable that these models
have been extricated from western life
as we know it.
So that's a key.
Must be a huge challenge.
He is,
and I,
I,
you know,
if in a perfect kind of scenario like
maybe people,
and it's so,
it's interesting,
people sometimes come into the APP and
they get to a point where they say,
actually,
I really,
you know,
where,
where did you train,
uh,
where did you do retreat?
As you kind of want to go and
investigate kind of that a little bit
more,
you know,
so the people who kind of follow on and
go go down that route.
And so sometimes I do feel like,
yes,
there is a,
a journey that can be delivered through
the APP,
but it's one part of the journey and
maybe at some stage some people will
want to go off and explore that,
you know,
outside of the APP as well.
Yes,
yes.
That is a,
like,
it's a departure point.
This is like good way of learning
meditation.
Um,
but another one of the things that must
be significant and it's something that
we've touched upon already,
is the use of language.
The words don't really like,
you know,
we were talking before
andy about how as soon as you start
talking about concepts,
we,
it becomes complicated.
It becomes complicated because you're
dealing with something somewhat
intangible.
I genuinely feel like the more,
the more we talk about
meditation,
the further we move away from the
experience.
So we could just say,
and not say anything for now,
but at the same time,
like you got to say something.
And so I,
I genuinely feel like that there has to
be some kind of conversation and it has
to be signposts and has to be guidance
as a,
there's an old parley kind of term.
Um,
and he's Kalina Mctier,
which is,
I believe that's from the lion king.
God,
God common.
Yeah.
I believe it's a warthog.
That's right.
The poly walked Paul.
And,
um,
so I think there's,
what does it mean that it means trusted
friend or kind of like trusted guide
and,
and for me that's the role that it's,
it's how to be kind of a rather than
kind of laying on concepts and saying
you should think in a certain way or you
should live in a certain
way,
it's more kind of,
okay look I went away and did this thing
and you know,
I find it really helpful.
Maybe I've done a little bit more than,
than some other people,
a little bit less than some other
people,
but I'm really happy to be like a
trusted guide into to use that
experience and to try to find a language
that worked for me.
And my hope is that it works for others
as well.
Definitely do.
And it really brilliantly.
That's fair.
Come on me.
I think you've cracked it now.
Like one of the great lies of our time,
it seems to me is the idea that the
personal liberty is freedom and personal
liberty means that we can be who we want
to be.
But I'm starting to understand that that
is not the case,
that there is no such thing as a vacuum.
There is no such thing as a sort of an
uninfluenced freedom.
What we have is I think we live in an
extremist consumerist culture that our
time is deeply influenced by ideologies,
so all pervasive that we can't see them
because they are everything.
It'd be like trying to identify
individual molecules of oxygen or
whatever.
So like with our opposing structures,
without alternative structures,
our role in civilization,
our role in society,
but it comes to consume.
We consume,
we don't know how to look at the world
differently.
We consume our politics,
we consume our news.
We have show business politicians now,
so there is a great necessity for
spirituality to get a foothold in
contemporary life.
Technology is going to be part of it.
In a way.
Headspace is a perfect product.
Are you surprised by the way that it's
gone by the place that you found
herself?
I'm not surprised the people have warm
to the idea of practicing meditation.
I think it's
timeless.
I think is universal.
It's been around for thousands of years.
The need,
you know,
people experienced anxiety and sadness
and anger back then.
You know,
there's in the same way that they do
now.
I think the difference is you say now
that it's almost like there's a bit of a
squeeze kind of and that we're all
feeding now,
squeeze,
feeling more overwhelmed by all those
things.
So I think yeah,
it's,
it's perhaps no surprise that more than
ever people are looking for for that.
My only concern about it is that in the
sense of urgency and need the,
it becomes in people's minds at least a
a fix rather.
So it's like how,
how I'm feeling stressed,
how do I fix that and not sleeping?
How do I fix that?
Rather than,
okay,
how do I understand my life or my mind
in relationship to stress or in
relationship to sleep?
And that meditation is about
understanding.
It's not about fixing something or
changing something.
So I feel like that's a very delicate
dance and balance that we're all kind of
engaged in state.
How,
how to,
on the one hand offer people the aspirin
because they have a headache and we
should treat the headache and at the
same time say wood's not about tree
treating the symptom.
It's about looking at and understanding
the underlying cause.
Is it,
does it have the potential to be
extremely dangerous in revolutionary?
Some of these ideas in that,
it seems to me that the natural end
point is it kind of throwing off the
shackles of our contemporary way of
life,
beyond even the external structures and
perhaps more importantly the internal
structures that make us victim to those
external ones.
If I,
if people start to say,
well,
there's more to life than consuming,
there's more to life than what I do for
a job.
What happens if community start forming
around different idea?
What happens then?
Yeah,
I mean I think that's a really
interesting idea.
You know,
and there's quite an exciting idea and I
don't think it's the differences.
I don't think it has to be this or that
in,
I don't think it has to be so kind of
extreme.
I,
I personally feel like it's quite
possible to,
to live in the world with the world as
it is,
but two at the same time to do that with
a sense of awareness and compassion and
you know,
that means that we're taking
responsibility for living the way that
we choose to live.
And perhaps as a result,
there were some ripples from that.
Hopefully the other people around us
kind of benefit from.
And maybe even some of those people
might kind of think,
hmm,
you know what?
Maybe I'll do a little bit of that.
So rather than it being sort of coerce
if in nature or any kind of sense of
pushing,
it's more just taking responsibility for
one's own sanity and a health and
relationships and then kind of seeing
what happens
as a result.
I think you're quite right about that
because I was thinking just as you spoke
that we are different men.
You and I that and the,
uh,
a monk and by nature is,
it seems that that journey is about,
there is some distinction,
some discretion,
some separation monastery.
Think about that sometimes when I was
young,
when I met that man,
that man is a matter of fact.
I said,
do you think I should become a monk?
Did you think he laughed at me when I
said it?
He laughed at the idea.
And this was,
that was then,
you know,
and,
but like,
I sometimes wish that I were,
I sometimes wish that there were robes
that didn't know what my position is in
the road.
The,
I don't believe in this.
This is not who I am.
And I don't want to talk about those
things,
you know,
but like I,
but,
but because I am a person that has found
flesh very,
very appealing and corrupting,
I've found drugs very,
very engaging.
I like senses.
I like sensuality.
I like the body.
So I've had to come to meditation,
Yoga,
spirituality with a gun to my head,
you know,
pretty much it's worth saying,
one,
I've not always been a monk.
Um,
so there were tight for a bit lunatic
biography and 21 years when I wasn't
monk.
And I haven't been a monk now,
right,
for 12 years.
And,
um,
you know,
I,
I have,
uh,
I have a wife and,
and I have kids.
And so it's,
it's in the same,
it might,
it might be different,
but in the same way,
it's not that I'm,
I'm unaffected by those things.
You know,
I was drawn to my wife because she was
beautiful and I found her beautiful.
And so I don't know if that's what
you're kind of talking about,
but I,
well,
in the,
I suppose it seems that you are,
when you answered that question about
like me saying,
because what I see when people talk
about spirituality,
I believe that like a connection to,
you know,
like the softly even take it,
whether it's at the extreme end of being
in a monastery somewhere in Tibet or
listening to headspace APP,
we're talking about a true for an
authentic relationship with this self in
inverted commerce that brings about
peace.
Now for me,
there's a good deep truth in that.
And the more people that have access to
that,
the truth is likely that that would have
limitless repercussions and will bring
about a lot of change.
And I feel that,
uh,
your,
I agree with you andy,
that we cannot start sort of like waving
flags and bashing down doors and there's
nothing more ridiculous than when you
read of conflict in Buddhist countries
and very full of like what's going on.
You've missed the point I suppose.
Any religion really.
It's like what the believe leave.
You've missed the point.
Yeah.
I wonder about expansionism I wonder
about evangelism because I feel that
there are ideas that are need to be,
that needs to be spread.
I don't think within the limited
conversation of contemporary politics as
solution will be found.
I think that they're just pulling
mutations and versions of each other.
I think most people think that they were
experiencing a time of grotesqueness,
of,
uh,
of nostalgia,
ethno nationalism,
old ideas,
this weird twitching flinching dinosaur
corpse thing with a wig on.
There's like a bit Kuli at time.
And I feel that precisely list solution
is to get in touch with essence,
essence as you described the Andy and,
and I feel that,
you know,
like,
you are
doing this thing that's means at 20
million people are meditating now and
it's really,
it's you that's doing it and it's good
that these good and episode and perfect
and necessary that you are a man that
has lived as a monk for 10 years and now
lives a lay person life.
Because that means that there is
authenticity.
Because if it was me doing it,
be like,
hang on a minute,
this,
that going to have to give her for
meditation,
the time is right.
You know,
like you're doing it with a few people
out there doing that.
I bet.
I bet there are.
But like this is authentic and true
foreign in spite the fact that there's
like comfortable animation and it's well
put together and it's,
you know,
when I,
when he showed me in that room that
you'd do the broadcast in a fire that
he's like a chapel,
you know,
it's silent.
It's dark,
it's sacred.
Yeah.
And,
and I think like any,
any place is not defined by how it
looks,
you know,
it's just like it's a recording studio.
But I think the feeling kind of in there
is,
um,
I,
I just think it's the same as anything,
right?
Like if we,
if we go to work in a particular kind of
space,
every space has its own kind of feeding
and we don't even have to be into that
sort of stuff.
You know,
that kind of language or vocabulary to
even experienced that.
We got to one place and we experienced
one kind of feeling.
We go to another places,
different kinds of fish.
Maybe we walk into a room with one
person,
they're angry,
we don't even talk to them,
but we know that they're angry.
There's a feeling kind of in the room.
So this kind of stuff exists even if we
just talk about it in,
in that sort of way.
So I think that's what's interesting,
that we don't necessarily have to go out
there and talk about it.
We can.
And I think it's exciting and it's good
that some people do,
especially within some kind of realms,
but specific to meditation,
I feel like if each and every one of us
takes on that responsibility to simply
to practice,
then over time that has an exponential
kind of effect because the feeling is
such that it starts to impact the lives
of the people around us.
You're right.
I think I spoke to David Lynch once
about meditation and about potentially
having confrontations with people on
air,
like going on tv shows and thinking,
oh,
I'm going to have to advocate for
meditation.
He says,
well,
there's no point in doing that.
Really just tell them,
learn to meditate and it will change.
It will change.
It's a practice.
It's something that alters your
consciousness.
Suddenly.
I've become aware of that.
Yesterday again when I was on that TV
set or talking to kids that are like I
guess 19 years old,
his beautiful young men and I'm struck
by how bright and brilliant and ready
and different they seem,
and I wonder if this is some perennial
quality of youth or young people are
changing now.
If people are ready,
if there can be some impersonal quality
to that,
uh,
God,
man,
Buddha kid,
then perhaps there are sort of
meteorological spirits traveling through
us.
I think there's this a change,
right?
There was a shift.
I do think,
um,
and definitely,
you know,
we,
we work a lot with,
with,
you know,
uh,
kids and teenagers written,
you know,
learning meditation and,
and I,
I do feel like,
do you have,
or do you mean by that work a lot with,
so,
so going into going into schools,
developing programs for specifically,
so meditation for children,
it's,
it's in app for them to do with their
parents or we've,
we've done,
you know,
working in schools as well,
um,
with the intention that it becomes part
of the school kind of curriculum and,
and my feeling is that they have watched
and learned from our experiences and
they want something different.
Yeah.
And there's,
there's a real kind of readiness and as
you say,
like a passion about that.
And I feel like as much as people kind
of give,
kids are really kind of tough time.
I actually feel that they're coming
through.
Yes,
they're challenged by all the
distractions of digital and everything
else,
but actually feel like they're more
altruistic in nature,
more socially minded than I've seen in a
long time.
Certainly our generation.
Um,
what do you,
uh,
when you're d does meditation work for
you,
right?
You've mentioned that you're married,
man,
you've got kids even been through that
sort of pre,
you've had quite difficult life and
you've lost a lot of people that you've
loved in your life.
I don't have,
is more difficult than anyone else's
life,
but definitely there was some,
there are some key things that have
happened that have influenced my own
journey.
Does it work,
you know,
the spiritual life,
does it work?
Is it effective when it comes to the
crunch,
when the pain comes,
when the divorce comes,
when people die,
when people leave you,
when you lose control of life and its
circumstances,
do you say to people,
this works this way of life?
Can you,
can you just,
what do you mean by work?
Does it help with pain and misery and
sadness and despair and loneliness and
agony and anguish?
[inaudible]
my wife's listening.
Um,
I'm not quite sure why those words.
I just mean that myself.
I know what you mean.
Cause the question that Gareth's
written,
actually,
it's normally Garrett's here doing these
things with me.
I'm not so generous as you are.
You Go,
oh,
like Richie set up,
may I just take the credit,
that's my function in life is to take
credit.
But like one of the questions he sort of
pointed out,
he goes,
he's seen like that me,
my way of dealing with life was I'm
going to take a lot of drugs.
I'm gonna do what's,
you know,
I'm going to do external things.
I'm going to get involved in the
material world.
Whereas evidently what you did is you
went,
I'm going to find another way and the
other path.
And,
and I did.
And I think,
I think he's so circumstantial.
I look in another,
in another town,
in an with another set of friends.
You know,
I just think it was so for all of us,
it's so specific to that time in that
place,
in that environment.
Um,
yes,
kind of.
I'd had meditation in my background,
you know,
like I'd grown up kind of doing it and
stuff and my mom.
And so that was,
that was in the background.
But definitely to begin with,
I think,
you know,
my immediate reaction was one to go to
the pub with everyone else,
you know,
and then kind of,
I probably spent a few years of doing
that and not really seeing a shift in
how I felt,
you know?
So I went away and it became a student
and did all the things that students do
and it was great fun.
But I never felt that I had any kind of
liberation beyond the,
the sense of,
you know,
temporary freedom that I might have had
for a few hours on,
on,
on a nighttime.
The next day you wake up.
And so I never felt that deep sense of
fulfillment that I felt was possible
straight away.
Yeah.
Fill that.
And then I went,
you bet at the time,
moment of reflection ever happening.
Well,
mine was maybe less extreme.
Just kill that moment of reflection.
That guy's got to go.
Yeah,
maybe I was,
I dunno.
Do you get angry still?
Do you get angry?
Of course.
What happens?
What do you do if you feel angry?
Um,
I mean I,
I tend not to run around kind of ranting
and raving at people.
I don't think it,
it manifests like that,
but you know,
I have a three and a half year old son
and an eight month old baby and we don't
sleep very much in the house.
So it's kind of inevitable at some stage
that that anger kind of comes up.
And as much as as possible,
it's,
it's trying to bring the practice to
life,
which is to,
is to witness it and not,
not to become the anger,
but to,
to notice the anger is,
is kind of present.
And sometimes I miss it.
Um,
you know,
as in I don't see it straight away and
so I'm already kind of on my son go,
Yep,
why don't you just do it?
That's anger.
Okay.
Sometimes you might want to jump off one
of those policy and cars and they'll
just remember are the side of the road.
Right?
Yeah.
Cause that's,
that's what I like thinking about it.
When we came without care,
me and my wife were like the first
couple of nights the baby's jet,
we're jet lagged and I still got,
I remember it being like four or five
o'clock in the morning and just go,
look,
we're going to have disease.
How can cause this depression?
I think this is wrong.
No it's no manipulation.
And my wife went and had lunch with jet
lag.
Yeah.
Like cause me,
I think I attached very quickly to
phenomena and states of mind so that I
need meditation.
I need to be able to go,
oh okay this is just,
you are not this feeling of anger.
You are not this fear.
The fear will pass and you will be
present now.
Like I still feel like even though it's
15 years since I've taken drugs or
drunk,
I still feel like I'm subjective fear in
a very powerful way.
Like I can be hit with fear that demands
activity is like I've gotten to have to
do something.
I'm feeling this feeling right.
Smashing everything up,
run,
you know.
And I like,
so it's very hard to just,
okay,
just breathe in.
So,
but you're saying because the meditate,
the meditative practice that you have,
and of course yours is a very
particular,
um,
Fara version actually is applicable in
situations where the free,
you know,
if you're all just kicking off or,
yeah.
I,
I actually think any meditation
practice which isn't applicable to daily
life,
uh,
yeah,
I kind of wonder what's the point a
little bit because I don't think any of
us,
you know,
it's not applicable in daily life,
but fucking exactly.
So people sit for 10 minutes and do the
meditate.
What about the other 23 hours and 50
minutes in the day?
So I feel like there has to be a way of
bringing that.
I just see it as if we can remove
ourselves from the madness of our lives
for long enough to get familiar with
what it means to be present,
what it means to be open and curious and
loving,
compassionate,
then we can start to bring those
qualities back into our everyday life.
And it's an ongoing kind of training.
And,
and I,
I love that back and forth,
you know,
where you know,
you know it's,
Oh wow.
Actually yeah,
that's still kind of happens.
Okay.
You go back to meditation and,
and over time that kind of,
it strengthens where meditation is no
longer separate from your life.
Meditation is simply a time within your
life or within your day when you pause
and close your eyes.
That's makes sense.
This thing I've been thinking about
lately,
like the relationship between the word
whole and the word holy,
that there is a sort of becomes an
identifiable wholeness to your life.
Meaning that if I'm out on my own and I
feel like,
uh,
an attractive person pays me attention,
I don't think,
oh brilliant.
I'm just this guy now.
I don't,
no,
no.
I'm the guy that's got the wife and the
child.
You are always that you are a complete
person.
You don't compartmentalize yourself off
into me,
Oh,
in this corner of my life I get away
with this.
This is the corner of my life where I do
that.
And then what is one thing?
There was one thing,
they were completeness.
And you think the meditation creates
some sort of connections and foundations
and essence?
Yeah,
no,
no question.
You know,
we were,
we were chatting about this,
um,
you met ash just before we came here and
I'll,
I'll buddy,
he's a lovely,
lovely guy.
And you know,
we grew up together and we were just
chatting kind of about this idea of um,
and,
and he was saying kind of when did you
first kind of really feel that,
you know,
and,
and I,
I still,
I still remember kind of being in,
in the monastery and something kind of
just melting away where I no longer felt
that extreme sense of self,
a sense.
And again,
I'm not suggesting for a moment that,
you know,
enlightenment or anything like this,
but just a glimpse perhaps of of what it
meant not to feel kind of isolated or
separate from the world.
And in that,
in that moment there wasn't,
there wasn't a person to be separate
from every,
there was only hole and there wasn't
even any one there to,
to experience and to think about it.
Is this the whole or is it not?
There's simply that was all that
existed.
Oh,
wicked.
And,
and I,
I feel like that was a low is it's just
an experience in those come and go.
And it all depends on how stable those
experiences are and how much can they
become a part of our lives.
For me it was quite temporary,
but I do feel like there was,
there was something kind of in that
which really spoke to a different way of
viewing the world.
You see Buddha and Jesus and that kid
you,
that 17 year old God man,
you met them catch.
Do you think they're living there?
You think that there's in that state all
the time?
It seems to be,
you know,
it,
there was,
um,
there's one other fight if I,
if I can.
So it was another monastery that I went
to,
to visit.
So there are this,
there's this a monastery for a second
pretty much monastery and monitoring.
Oh,
want to transcend,
you've had enough transcendent to get
out,
go back to your wife,
monastery,
Gulf.
It was,
um,
there was,
there's a kind of an elite troop of kind
of meditators,
right?
So they,
um,
within this tradition they get picked
out the cad you school,
um,
of,
so there were four main ones in Tibet.
Cadre was one of the four.
What's that alarm or he's a good look.
Um,
and he's,
he's very well known obviously because
of his just transcendent wisdom and
compassion.
But he's also,
he was also the head of government for a
long time and sort of,
although he's not the head of all four
schools,
he's kind of,
he's probably better known in the West
than anyone else.
And in this monastery,
um,
they,
they pull the kids out pretty young and
obviously the kids have to want to do
it.
They have to,
and they have to show a real kind of,
um,
what's the word?
Like a lot of potential in meditation.
The families have to be on board as
well,
and they're picked out and from about
the age of 10 or 11 they're in strict
retreat.
They never go outside,
they never see anyone speak to anyone or
anything.
And we were invited to this monastery
and it's very,
very rare to meet anyone from that
thing.
And then the guy who ran it was,
he lived above the monastery and I was
with this chap,
Donald,
and I think because I was with this chap
donal,
we were invited to go and see him and
going into that room,
I went in there,
there were four of us that went in
again,
that that is someone I would say who was
absolutely living that sense of
wholeness in,
I don't believe there was an ounce of
separation kind of left in him.
He was there,
but he wasn't there.
It was,
there was nothing but a presence of
again,
awareness,
compassion,
openness,
love,
whatever you want to kind of call it or
define it.
There was,
there was someone there,
but there was nobody there.
Yeah.
And I felt like he was,
he had completely transcended itself.
So that that was his existence.
It's like the realization that your
biographical identity and your primer,
you're sort of primal motivations,
your last a jealousy,
fear or even personal love,
our temporal interpretations.
And if your identification with the
interpreter,
the witness,
the experience becomes your base,
your essence,
then there is freedom
because curiously it's a colloquialism
again.
After I met that Geezer adding that
Swami and I went to my mate Matt
Huskies,
it's weird.
Right?
And it goes,
I couldn't imagine there's anything you
could say to him that would knock him
off.
He said like,
yeah,
like,
and my mate went like,
yeah,
what if you went might as some skin,
it's fucking up your car.
Whoa.
I wouldn't like there's nothing you
could say or like,
do you want to be in our band?
He wouldn't go all right.
Yeah.
They're like,
you're,
there's nothing.
There is nothing to get,
there is nothing to lose.
Yeah.
Hmm.
So yeah,
I'm really into it.
The other thing is though with Amma,
the hugging saint who I also feel like
she emanates great wisdom and I'd have
followers think,
but you know,
they're very in like that Hindu as you
know better than me.
Like they're much more idolatry based.
So they're saying this woman is an
incarnation of carly or some,
you know,
they say she's got,
yeah now like I was watching her and
she's amazing and powerful and visibly
going into China,
send an states and stuff like that.
But there's this big night,
right?
It was New Year's eve and I have 10,000
followers hanging out and like,
you know,
sort of his big party and chanting.
It was cool and she's up,
you know,
enthroned and stuff.
There's a bit where someone,
a musician like messed up something and
I've actually just been always sought
out,
finger out,
like in whatever southern Indian
language she speaks.
She went and sought sorta thing out of
all,
she's still interacting with the
material world.
Here's why one though.
And they sort of say in Christianity and
Christ says like,
you know,
in the world,
but not of it.
Yeah.
You,
what do you feel about perennialism?
What do you feel about identifiable,
uh,
truths that are appear in many,
if not all spiritual traditions.
I also,
again,
I think that the more that we,
the more that we rely on words and
concepts,
the further we move away from truth.
So the,
the challenge always I think with these
great teachers is that there's always an
essence there.
And there's,
you know,
it's often talked about is sort of
mystical schools,
but I just think there's an essence and
the essence is to be,
is awareness and compassion for what,
I can't find other other words but that
it's called by many names,
but you know,
for the,
for the sake of this,
it's called at call it that I feel like
that's at the heart of every,
every lineage,
every tradition,
every faith,
every tradition.
And I just feel that the further it kind
of moves outwards and as it moves out
into society,
the less and less it has to do with the
essence.
And the more and more it has to do with
a structure,
often a structure reliant on,
you know,
the power and government and all kinds
of other kind of factors that start to
play into it.
So all of a sudden like the essence is
lost.
And so people are doing things and going
through the motions of things and not
even really kind of necessarily knowing
what they're doing or why they're doing
or even having the benefit of
experiencing the essence of that kind of
practice.
So,
and let us obviously kind of very
general and broad and it's not true in
every case,
but I,
I see it a lot.
Um,
and I've,
I saw in Asian countries as well,
he'll often,
this is,
you know,
in the west,
we like this in the east at,
I mean I saw that in just as much in
Asian countries as I did in,
in the west.
And even in your monastic experience,
you said,
you know,
there's gap at this time,
eat this.
But when we discussed it before,
it was more like,
look,
let's eliminate as much as possible all
the Ephemera of everyday affairs.
So you can focus on awareness and
compassion.
Cultivate in these qualities.
Yeah.
But that itself is a form of structure,
but it is in evidence that we go from
Christ,
the idea of Christ,
of like,
you know,
abandoned your possessions and follow
me.
Don't get caught up in material world,
loves everything.
Don't judge nobody to write.
I'm going to need cathedrals.
Yeah.
Like it's a sort of,
it becomes materialized,
institutionalized.
And that is not about this essence is
it?
No.
And that's what I,
that's what really moved me and look is,
is,
is absolutely the same in,
in all mystical schools,
whether it's Christianity or Sufism of
Islam.
Like you can find it in many in all the
great traditions.
But what really inspired me,
you know,
with the,
the great yogis of Tibet,
you know,
they,
they issued all that stuff.
They didn't want anything to do with any
kind of,
not even the monasteries.
They would just go to a cave in the
mountains and they break it up and,
and they'd have a little hole in one
corner where they pass their waste out
of.
They'd have a little hole in the other
corner where someone would come along
every now and again and put some food
inside and they would live their lives
there and it was,
it was free from all that kind of other
stuff.
And whilst on the one hand it's,
it's not very kind of practical.
I think on the other hand it created an
environment where the focus and the
intention was on the essence and the
cultivation of the essence and the
continuance of the essence through the
ages rather than trying to create these
greatest establishments that maybe kind
of didn't necessarily kind of have to
focus and intention on the,
on the essence,
no,
their social structures and social
structures tend to,
the magnetism seems to be towards power.
We talked before about polarity and
concepts such as positive and negative
and even these you issue the evening
these,
well I think from a meditation point of
view they're,
they're really challenging.
So most of us will have a relationship
with the mind where we kind of all with
thoughts where we see some thoughts as
positive and we see some thoughts as
negative.
So in doing that,
we've already created a framework for
tension and stress.
If you know of positive thoughts come
up,
we want to hold onto them or you want to
chase after them and if they look like
they're going away,
we get a little bit kind of nervous or
we desire them so much that we chase
after them.
So we're caught up in that.
If a negative thought comes up,
we don't like it,
we maybe we experience fear or were very
resistant to it.
So we then kind of pushing against the
thought.
But when we then you'll know,
you know,
I'm sure you know this from your own
meditation or when you,
when you step back just a little bit,
you know,
a thought is a thought and if we don't
engage with it,
if we're able to kind of maintain that
place,
that seat of awareness where we simply
witness a thought coming and going,
it's a thought.
It's neither good nor bad.
It only becomes good or bad.
Once we start to think about it in a
certain way and once we start to have a
relationship with it and to engage with
it and to create a storyline around it,
then it becomes problematic.
But I thought in and of itself is
neither is neither positive or negative
in a way for is the first layer of the
material world.
It's an object.
Yeah.
I I,
yeah,
I think that some,
I mean there's always different ways of,
of looking at it,
but I feel like that's the first,
the first,
uh,
normally the first place where we kind
of get a bit caught up and where we
start to experience suffering and stress
in our life.
Because even though like I've been
meditating in seven years,
transcendental meditation,
I been listening to headspace and like,
you know,
I'm listening to the beginners bit,
right?
Cause it's free.
I thought I Weiss of so odds but credit
card number into something like,
Oh God,
no,
this feels like a real commitment.
But like,
but like so,
so,
but even though like when I'm listening
and then 10 minute ones,
I'm like,
bloody hell,
this is for proper beginners,
like Lard,
recommend to mates and mine are out
lights did in driveways and that guy
look,
listen to this,
this will be of your meditation.
But me,
I've been meditating all this time and I
still like,
you know that right.
You probably maybe wandered off now just
returned back to the awareness of the
rising and falling Nebraska and bloody
oh,
I am just saying yeah.
Thinking again.
Yeah.
You know,
he's sort of like,
it's being stylish in this habit of the
mind.
Yeah.
It's incredible,
right?
It's so ingrained and there's does this,
um,
sometimes this idea that,
you know,
your friends will say,
oh,
or people who meditate was how yeah,
you went away and he did it for kind of
so low,
so low.
We'll kind of,
so what in a way it does,
it doesn't mean that I no longer
experience distraction of the mind.
I think it,
it is a practice and I,
I really believe that none of us really
kind of mastered is that maybe the odd
few people like you know,
people we've been chatting about today,
but I feel like it is a,
is a lifelong practice.
He said journey for life and we're all
students.
We are always a student and if we ever
lose that sense of not being a student,
then we've lost that sense of freshness
and curiosity and openness and
beginner's mind,
which I feel is so important in
meditation.
If we're not turning up with that,
then it's just a routine.
We just kind of going through the motion
assignment,
think about little kids be in,
you know,
taken off right there.
Maybe seven years old,
they're 11 years old.
It just seems extraordinary as a person
who's grown up in the culture at I have
that.
That would even be an option.
But I suppose,
yeah,
you think about it with football,
you'd take off a six year old trough in
some football academy,
but the idea that you would an 11 year
old would be capable of that and it
shows you how much cultural experiences
in the world knowable to,
I think candy,
that fear and desire,
the constant triggers to action are so
prevalent culturally that the news is
promoting fear that commerce if rounds
on desire,
but these animalistic states a
perpetuated that we need,
uh,
in,
an alternative if not oppositional force
an ideology because the Po,
the,
the magnetism is powerful.
The magnetism,
the alternative is powerful.
Yeah.
I guess it depends how we,
and again,
different viewpoints on it,
but how we approached that.
So if there's one idea,
do we try and,
do we try?
I think very often you'll see one idea
and you,
she's in a,
in American politics right now,
there's one idea presented and then the
other side they just shout a little bit
kind of louder and then this side shouts
louder.
And then this side til eventually the
kind of,
you know,
there's,
there's so much kind of conflict and I
guess there's a,
there are different ways of coming at it
and,
and arguably the way of creating that
alternative kind of route is rather than
by trying to overthrow that in a kind of
a,
a physical or energetic kind of way,
more kind of not engaging paps and
creating an environment where that can't
exist now.
Because if all of us are,
are living an open,
present,
compassionate kind of life,
no one's going to vote for that.
Yes.
You know,
so we,
we enable,
you know,
I feel like the society enables that
behavior.
It doesn't necessarily,
it's not necessarily,
we're not necessarily slaves to it.
We all kind of part of that and each and
every one of us has a responsibility to
sort of,
you know,
to,
to be more present perhaps and not
engage in it.
I think that's beautiful.
I've heard that I did from various
different sources,
even quite,
you know,
anarchists and quite political people,
right.
People that are sort of progressive,
uh,
[inaudible] ideas of setting up
societies that are independent,
saying that don't engage in opposition
Ism simply establish alternatives,
established alternatives and living it.
And when I think about them,
two boys that was talking to yesterday
were young men.
Yeah.
Like I think yeah,
they are not going to want to like if
you give them that right,
here is a system.
He was an alternative system.
Like the way we can live in the world
and we admit that the NAC is a woven
material in it with consuming in it.
We've where we acumen and we're frail
and we we're flawed.
Yeah.
It doesn't,
we don't have to live in the extremist
state that are currently being offered.
Even see that inside our own mind.
Right.
That we almost fanned the flames when we
provide a lot of opposition or a lot of
conflict.
Like it doesn't,
it keeps the thing alive.
He know.
So I worry sometimes that if the more we
kind of push in one direction,
actually the more sort of tension we
create kind of coming back towards us.
It's a bit like I Quito or something.
You know,
you,
if the,
if the force is coming towards you
rather than push against it,
just move to the side,
let it go past,
you know,
there's something interesting in that
kind of movement.
Yeah.
It feels like we plug into it.
I think about bumper cars quite often
that they know that we're these vehicles
that have an area when it goes into the
grid of negativity and anger.
And if we just sort of unplug from that,
then you're not being sourced by in the
same way.
And I do think we can live in the world,
but choose not to be a part of that kind
of thinking.
I agree.
Can I run for some of these questions
that Garath Dan just selling,
make sure that everything's covered.
Uh,
are you still in touch with teachers in
Tibet,
like your guru in that and who is your
guru and you still study with him?
Uh,
I'm very much still in touch with them.
I,
you know,
we were chatting just beforehand.
I showed you a picture of our,
it was really nice.
I had a,
uh,
one of the,
the abbots from the Tibetan monasteries.
Um,
my old retreat master,
he came out and visited everybody's name
out.
He's La Llama.
Yes.
She ran pushy.
Ah,
cool.
[inaudible] name,
which is normally always impressed when
I see them on a book.
It's quite,
quite high up.
Those,
those guys,
they've done their,
they've done their time and lane,
he,
he's not applying.
Um,
and it was amazing.
I was,
I was so mad at you or they love you,
they're happy or they seem really happy.
And I was,
I was genuine.
It,
that's probably one of the most magical
special times for me personally,
kind of in the whole headspace journey
is having him come out here.
Um,
he spent a day with the whole team kind
of,
um,
our,
our annual retreat and um,
and sort of know that it was his stamp
of approval,
but him coming out here,
it kind of felt like,
wow.
Like that was really kind of meaningful
cause it,
you know,
there is always the concern when you're
trying to present something that has
been so carefully kind of looked after.
That's kind of traveled so many
centuries,
you know,
of of messing with it.
You know,
and I,
something I really calm,
really care about.
It's probably the thing I care about
most.
And so him coming out here and kind of
saying this is,
this is really kind of good for the
world.
That meant,
yeah,
I meant a huge amount.
That's beautiful isn't it?
Because that's one of the great
challenges is how do we transfer it?
Uh,
people have,
can't see,
but you did it as if you were carrying a
baby bird got to carry this thing is
going to go in the wall.
Precious,
you know,
and I think it's really easy to lose
again,
two and a half thousand years of r and d
like,
what's that?
R and D is sort of research development
kind of,
you know,
I feel like it'd be so easy to lose the
efficacy in all the time and attention
and precision that's gone into that over
countless lifetimes.
And so I don't want to be the person
that messes that up,
you know,
come up with this thing.
Add,
reiterate.
Then Andy there I got,
what is it that like,
what is it that,
uh,
what is the teaching of Buddha?
And it's quite big question to come up
with.
Could you just sum that up,
please end it.
And I like him but like,
cause this is is it's Buddhism.
This headspace I genuine even as a
Buddhist monk,
I didn't um,
self identify as Buddhist,
um,
and deluded may monitoring wrapped in a
blanket.
What did he think he was a hell's angel?
Probably that's what you're going to be
off to the circus.
I don't,
I just don't call it as not helpful.
I just think that the whole,
the whole idea of,
of meditation is letting go of labels
and identity.
So it was kind of ironic we then kind of
take on and adopt the label of,
of being a Buddhist or a Hindu or
whatever it kind of might be.
So I personally didn't find that
terribly helpful way of thinking.
Um,
definitely.
I,
I personally,
obviously I practiced those teachings
for a very long time.
They're very much kind of a part of my
life and they absolutely a hundred
percent influence kind of the content.
Um,
and a responsible for the content.
[inaudible] it's in the APP,
but I,
I don't think about it as Buddhist.
You know,
we talked just now about the essence,
the essence that is alive in every great
tradition and every great culture.
I feel like it is the delivery of the
essence.
Um,
so it's that as the chocolate without
the wrapper.
Yes.
Imagine that if Jesus,
Mohammed and Buddha met,
they will not have a fight,
but they ain't go no,
fuck you.
It's the same thing.
It's hard to imagine.
I quite like just be at that dinner
though.
What they talk.
I mean,
I wonder,
yeah,
like,
uh,
but like,
yeah,
ultimately you're right,
the label people get hung up on the
labels.
People get hung up on the denominations.
But I suppose like the,
you know,
coming from a Hindu tradition,
the transformation of Buddhism was what
exactly fair.
Still a big question,
isn't it?
But like,
what was it like suffering and desire?
Watch out for that crap.
I little bit of that,
I think dude,
um,
the recognizing that,
cause I'm trying to work out is that
what happened to that man under that
tree?
Yeah.
Relevant to me now it feels like it is.
Cause I again,
I I think these things are,
they're timeless.
I think they're,
they're universal.
And it's really interesting,
you know,
you were talking about kind of
attraction to,
to,
to the flesh and all those kinds of,
to even if you read those stories,
like it's not like he was there and he
was experiencing this perfect mind and
there were,
there were no thoughts of desire or lost
or greed or desire.
All of that stuff was there.
He was tempted was neen all sorts of
forms and figures.
I met him,
he was picturing kind of beautiful naked
women.
And I don't feel like that's really such
a kind of great leap away from where we
are and have been most of us in,
in our lives.
It's just there was such a kind of a
commitment to an intention to see those
for what they were,
you know,
simply as thoughts and not real.
And not permanent and not,
and in,
in
having that relationship and that
perspective with his mind,
with his thoughts,
there was,
there was a release and therefore,
uh,
a permanent at some stager,
a complete freedom from the,
the,
the suffering of kind of our thinking
mind.
Yes.
Is there some beautiful,
beautiful stories I felt,
um,
like,
like I said to you mate,
when I left my wife and a daughter not
permanently banned in the family just
for a minute while I did this at Abbot
Kinney and wander around there on the
short walk,
I felt like the thought occurred,
I am already dead.
You are already dead.
Everything that happens to you,
it's meaningless.
Now those are thought you get get often.
No,
not really,
but it gets off the light.
I get versions of like,
I think it exists to,
uh,
to mitigate the for that there's some
thing to acquire,
to attain.
I'm very much a person that's I'm
objective,
fixated.
Like I think I must do this.
I must get that,
you know,
cause even when you sort of like that
when people do at in enlightenment,
cause I took psychedelics when I was
younger,
I recognize it cause I've shortcutted it
sometimes when you get that feeling of
self immolation and the idea of like,
oh my God,
I'm not real.
I remember like I was 16 year old kid,
I took acid.
We've just like lads from now as it
turned out like the Yorkshire,
like tripping and like,
and I remember,
Oh my God,
I'm not a person.
I know like I remember realizing it and
feeling it and like it's terrifying
because you are,
there's no,
we don't have any tradition.
There's nothing to tell you that there's
no one's going all right,
this is just this temporary thing.
You're going to be here for a brief
while,
you know.
So,
yeah,
those thoughts occur to me and have
always occurred to me and I've always
had,
uh,
I've found something in me that does
make me think that past life or some
version of that or interconnected
consciousness in some form maybe a deal
because it like often thinks,
seem familiar.
Often things seem attractive to me in
ways that are,
you know,
like you spoke of your own instinct,
your own intuition.
You decided at some point I'm mafia to
go to the Himalayas.
Like,
what's that?
Oh,
I'm going to go and study with this guy.
You know,
who is that?
Who's that?
That speaking?
Who is me and like Adam Curtis on the
early guests on this podcast goes,
the problem of our time now is there's
someone in our air,
you know,
the pink floyd lyric.
There's someone in my head and it's not
me.
There's someone talking inside your own
mind and that's not who you are.
I've got to do this.
I'm going to buy that.
I'm going to have a fight,
aren't going to perhaps that you know,
you've become identified,
commodified condition,
the trained to behave in a way that you
are now completely detached from this
essence,
this essence that you talk about this
awareness and compassion who have no
relationship with it anymore.
Don't know that it's there.
And that's,
that's the interesting thing for me.
I think the,
and I agreed that the risk is that we
think that it's,
that it's elsewhere.
If we think it's not there or not here,
then we might start to think
that it exists elsewhere.
And,
and I would contend that actually it is
here and he is with each and every one
of us all of the time.
It's never anywhere else.
It's just that maybe we don't have a
sense of connection with it or we don't
have a familiarity with it.
And I feel that's the struggle.
And a lot of people come to meditation
rather than kind of allowing sort of the
clouds the past to experience the blue
sky.
There's more of a sense of,
okay,
right,
I've got to experience blue sky.
How do I push all those clouds out of
the way and how do I kind of create this
space?
Like what I think meditation is rather
than just allowing a natural process to
unfold.
So I,
despite,
you know,
whatever's going on in the world and
whatever people are doing and saying,
I think for all of us or this is
something I find really kind of useful
is,
is knowing that look,
awareness and compassion is still there
for whatever reason,
the circumstances that conditioning the
environment as not necessarily allowed
that to shine through.
But it is there and it's there in each
and every one of us.
I really sort of profoundly kind of
believe,
believe that's the case.
Clearly.
Willie,
can we conclude with some meditation?
There are other questions,
but you know,
they're not as interesting as the idea
of ass though.
Great questions.
Gaff,
tape be hurt.
Like they've got like a like should we,
can we conclude the call meditation?
We do a bit.
Yeah.
If you'd like to.
Oh,
nice one.
Yeah.
Couple of minutes.
Good or,
yeah.
Yeah,
a couple of minutes.
Great.
I mean you're the bloody expert.
I,
I'm really not.
Let me decide.
Coke,
I don't think,
I don't think there's ever been,
um,
have ever been done in this particular
right.
Won't help us.
Okay.
So know whether it's just us.
I sort of is.
Anyone who wants to kind of join him
when they're,
when they're listening to this,
you know,
just um,
general bit of advice.
Just make sure that you're sitting
comfortable and you're not going to be
disturbed for just a couple of,
a couple of minutes.
It doesn't matter if there's a bit of
noise going on in the background,
but just taking a moment,
always when you first sit down,
just a,
just to ground the body,
so just feel the weight of the body
against the chair or the floor beneath
you.
Soles of the feet on the floor and the
weight of the hands and the arms just
resting on the legs and you can start
off with your eyes open,
eyes closed,
whatever feels kind of more comfortable.
But if you have your eyes open,
just drive your camera.
Other than to focus on one particular
point,
just have a nice kind of spacious,
relaxed focus.
It's sort of just takes in the entire
sort of space around you so you can't
really see any one thing in focus.
You just see everything around you and
just maintaining that soft focus.
Just tell you a couple of big deep
breaths.
Breathing in through the nose and out
through the mouth.
Just one more time.
Breathing in through the nose,
announce for the mouth,
and as you breathe out this time just
gently closing the eyes and just feeling
that weight again,
pressing down.
Allow any thoughts to just come and go.
The mine's going to continue to think.
Don't try to stop any thoughts,
just bringing the attention into the
body.
I'm just noticing how the body feels.
Is there a sense of heaviness or
lightness in the body?
Does it feel like there's a sense of
stillness or restlessness in the body?
So not trying to change anything.
Just noticing the feeling,
that sensation and as you sit there,
just starting to notice how the body's
breathing.
So again,
we're not trying to breathe in any
special way.
Sometimes the breath will be quick.
Sometimes it's slow,
sometimes it's deep,
sometimes it's shower.
Just let it do its own thing.
Okay?
To begin with,
just noticing where in the body you feel
that movement might be.
The stomach won't be the chest,
you can't fit anything.
Just gently placing your hand on the
stomach just to feel that movement as
you follow the breath.
Just the help to to remain focused on
that feeling,
that sensation.
Just starting to count the breaths just
silently to yourself.
So as you fill the rising sensation,
it count one falling sensation two and
three and four just up to a count of 10.
You starting again at one.
Just try that a couple of times through
on your own.
So for sure at some stage the mind's
going to get distracted.
Soon as you realize the mind's wandered,
just gently acknowledging it,
letting the thought co and then just
coming back to the brain.
And just for a moment,
okay,
letting go nav even any focus on the
breath.
So just letting the mind for a few
seconds.
Do whatever it wants to do.
It wants the thing that I think just
allowing the mind to be free and then
just gently bringing the attention back
into the body that's coming back to that
feeling of contact of weight coming back
into the space around you.
Any sounds,
sensations,
and then when you're ready,
just gently open the eyes again.
Thank you.
Ah,
that was good because it was mad 12th my
and like you were there.
Oh,
hello.
I'm there all the time there.
It's that man for that team guys in here
as well.
And that was amazing.
Thank you very much.
The idea that it is always there,
the awareness and compassion is always
there.
Obfuscated only by men or static and
external attachment,
which can be overcome with the learning
of these techniques.
Well done in your incredible work in big
team.
Yeah,
no,
yeah,
absolutely.
You know,
you've been very clear that you work
with a great many people and that you're
part of a lineage in a yeah.
In both directions laterally and back
for the time.
Hopefully forwards as well.
Yeah.
Hopefully unless you,
this finally ruined.
I mean,
is it good chance?
We'll see what happens between us.
You can destroy all religion.
There's nothing left.
But the thing,
I'll do the board and then we'll branch
out,
branch out.
Christianity.
Islam will leave.
I was involved with that,
but hey,
nice one.
Thanks.
Right.
It's an honor to have you for having me
on,
man.
Thank you.
Thanks for letting us record in your
studio.
Um,
the,
so yeah,
download the headspace.
Learn to meditate free yourself.
Free Yourself.
Cheers mate.
Thanks man.
Nice one.
Thank you.
Yes.